[Music]
Senator John McCain was photographed
playing poker on his iPhone during John
Kerry's presentation on Syria and yeah
it shocked a lot of people I'm surprised
people were shocked I am it's no secret
online poker has been a part of
congressional hearings for years just
look at this footage from c-span you're
watching c-span and live from Washington
DC at the heart set building it's the
senatorial hearing poker challenge and
here we go John Kerry oblivious to the
poker game going on around him he's
talking about the very serious subject
of Syria but over here McCain is sitting
on a pair of aces and Jack's going
strong he's gonna raise five g's don't
put the bed over to the Washington Post
McGill away who sees the race he likes
his three of a kind
Menendez not liking what he has he's out
Leahy also folds as does Sullivan
Barnwell Ellison Burkett not short and
they're out as well Coons also sees the
raise and adds another 5k neither our
country nor our conscience okay that
makes Durbin wisely fold I've came back
to McCain McCain calls okay we're ready
for the river McCain with a full house
that's why he's the one to be
[Applause]
[Music]